we got a
jobs report that just kind of smashed it
guys can go over the numbers real quick
to you guys up but uh we had the
non-farm payrolls jobs report come out
for the month of june this was one that
was closely watched and
we had uh nfp come in at 372 000 in the
month of june um versus expectations of
268 000.
um also we did see the revision here so
i should mention that
that um we had a revision in may to 384
thousand
um
so the change in non-non-farm payment
payroll sorry uh for april was revised
down by 68 000 and that was down from
400 to 400 from 436 000 to 368 000 and
the change for may was revised down by 6
000 so you did have some revisions here
unemployment rate continues to remain
flat at 3.6
um average hourly earnings month over
month was
uh just three tenths of a percent um
and then or
that month every month was uh sorry i'm
like stumbling all over the place here
um average hourly earnings a year every
year we're up 5.1 percent
versus expectations of 5
and the number probably to watch was
labor force participation that rate
declined unexpectedly to 62 percent from
62.3
versus estimates of 62.4 percent
so
guys jobs report much better than
expected something folks are definitely
watching especially as we have the
federal reserve um raising rates lately
so
any uh takeaways for you guys i mean i
think it's interesting because it was
strong right we've uh we obviously went
through a period i was looking at the
chart earlier uh if you look through
covet and back we went from about 152
million uh non-farm employees all the
way down to 130 and now we're back up to
that 152 numbers so we've almost fully
recovered now to that point uh if not
even more if not even higher and it's
the strongest job market it's been in
nearly uh half a century right so we've
uh uh we've done a really good job
coming back from that on the job side
but it's interesting because basically
everything outside of this is signaling
a recession is is coming or already here
in some instances right what we've seen
is the federal reserve is trying to get
uh play catch up to some of these things
now with hiking the rates in such a fast
and aggressive manner and i think
they'll probably continue that but it's
interesting to see uh such a strong jobs
report in the face of high inflation and
recessionary fears
yeah it's a strong jobs report but when
you look historically like we've added
more jobs than this before right for the
last few months now we've added between
two hundred thousand four hundred
thousand jobs every single month for
about four months now but when you look
back i think what in february of this
year we had 714 000 jobs in the non-farm
payroll right so when you look at it
that way yes it beat expectations but
there are still layoffs happening um so
it's kind of like give and takes people
think we're either in a recession and
we're going towards that way or hey look
the economy is doing all right people
are hiring more non-farm payrolls are
happening uh month over month right so
we're heading in the right direction uh
but we're still catching up to what
happened from covid but as joe's point
we're almost there i think like what's
interesting is um the labor force
participation we just had that chart up
there we can pull that up again
but this just came out i just saw a
tweet that came out from double line
capital and they just pointed out that
the labor force shrank by roughly 350k
causing a decline in the labor force
petition participation rate by to
decline by one tenth tenth of a percent
to the 62.2 percent they also pointed
out um that prime age labor force
participation of the 25 to 54 year olds
decreased by three tenths of a percent
to 82.3 percent so just that's probably
something the fed would probably want to
look at is the labor force participation
i'd imagine
that one seems to be one that folks
keep bringing up um we also just had
some other interesting data this week
around just what's kind of going on in
the labor story um because
it's it to me like when we talk about
recession
this kind of seems to be like the bright
spot in the economy still but there's
just it's just bizarre to me so we have
the jolts number come out this week the
number of job openings fell to 11.3
million in the month of may that's
according to the job openings and labor
turnover survey or jolts
which was above the medium estimate of
11 million
um but below remember back in april we
had 11.3 million
job openings like it's just amazing to
me just the sheer number of job openings
out there
i don't know how you guys feel about
that but
i i think part of it too yeah and uh
they're certainly uh 10 to some extent
right a little over 10 million it seems
now uh but i think also part of this is
people have been reluctant to fire
people right
the people uh that have employees that
are still showing up and even if they're
not doing the highest quality of work
that maybe they want um the inability
with the the rate so low at this point
uh relative to where we were a year ago
to go out and hire other employees and
the costs associated with that i think
has played a huge part in not firing
employees or not moving on from
employees that they would have otherwise
done uh maybe six months ago 12 months
ago or even a year ago yeah yeah it's a
tough spot to look at because
historically employers have all the
power they determine who works for their
company like you don't have to give
great benefits as long as you're like a
good company and pay well like people
are going to come to your company the
problem is is in may we had
two open jobs for every unemployed
person in america right so you can't
fill all those open jobs so employees
essentially get the power and then what
we saw during covid was that employees
were there now we're back to employers
have the power again right um so it's an
interesting dynamic that we've seen
shift a few times over the last few
years but we're moving back to that
narrative that um it's gonna be a little
more 50 50 with who has the power in
that occult relationship uh because
employers need workers and employees
need jobs right uh so it's going to be a
give and take yeah probably the area to
watch though and we keep talking about
it is just what's happened in tech um
seems like you keep hearing about
layoffs um but yeah i always check like
layoffs.fyi.com just or not not just
layoffs.fyi is always like a good um
place where they aggregate it but let's
move on and talk about um bitcoin um
bitcoin is actually up let's check the
price today not that we always like
check the price here but
it i noticed it was okay so it's above
twenty one thousand seven hundred
fourteen right now so it's up three
point eight
six percent right now um today and
there's an interesting study that came
out about 140 billion that's ready to
pounce um so i actually went through
some of this but i'll i'll tee it up for
you guys but it was digital assets
digital asset investment management
analysts put out a recent note
um and it was a bit of a forecast on
what's going on in crypto but basically
they're saying um
that there's this
a lot of dry powder we keep bringing up
dry powder on the sidelines that's ready
to go into the crypto space so we can
pull up a chart i think we have a chart
here
um on just what's happening in the
stable market
there you go right there so
um what they said was um the ecosystem
has an additional 140 billion ready to
be deployed into bitcoin and alt
to put it in perspective the market cap
of bitcoin bitcoin and ethereum in march
of 2020 was 140 billion combined
um with 124 billion of that being in
bitcoin respectively for the market cap
and they said they continued these
analysts wrote when markets are crashing
everyone wants dry powder in order to
cash in on discounted assets uh the most
efficient way to do this is through
stable coins so
your reaction
i think uh the comments that interested
me was was sam beckman freed the other
day who basically said that um he
believes a lot of the pain is over at
least in the short term when it comes to
uh companies that were extremely
leveraged or levered or doing uh
somewhat inappropriate things right in
the market uh talking about tara
celsius uh through aeros capital et
cetera what companies that have
significantly um
put the risk management of other
companies into the uh kind of the
limelight and sam and ftx have obviously
done a tremendous job kind of
backstopping some of these companies are
providing capital where needed he said i
think that they have another two billion
dollars or even maybe more than that to
continue to do that if it's necessary
but he believes that some of these uh
some of these products or services or
businesses that have uh gone under over
the last few weeks that that was the
worst of it right and now we're gonna
get to a point in time where a lot of
the leverage has been wiped out uh some
of the people who were maybe doing uh
unexpected or inappropriate things in
the market from that perspective maybe
even illegal things to some extent
depending on kind of uh what you look at
or what you're talking about has been
wiped out and now we're going to head to
a spot which is much more uh comfortable
and regulated and or potentially
regulated but also uh can give us a good
landing spot going forward so i think
that's an important point because he's
obviously been in the thick of this from
not only uh giving out money and buying
some of these companies or providing
loans but also um making sure that that
ftx and their shareholders are armed
going forwards
when you look at stable coins the top
three stable coins the market is 140
billion right so a lot of the other
stable coins are insignificant when you
look at it in the grand scheme of things
um and the dry powder thing is
interesting everyone's trying to guess
right now where the bottom of the market
is have we hit it have we not hit it yet
are we still going to go lower right
everyone's trying to predict the future
um and that's just one thing everyone's
trying to get dry powder uh and when
everyone runs to go get their dry powder
on the way down prices fall even farther
everyone can deploy their dry powder at
a good position but it's just how are
you gonna time it are you gonna try to
time the market uh where do you get in
out everything etc um but you you can
tell that people are definitely
people are definitely storing dry powder
and waiting to deploy it in a lot of
cases especially in crypto and you were
talking about sam beckman free he's got
a lot of dry powder it sounds like a
couple billion yeah yeah i i liked in
this analyst no they just said max payne
and bitcoin generally means max
opportunity there will be a time when
the negative news runs out so
a bit of optimism there
any other thoughts some much needed
optimism
there you go um we should also bring up
elon musk he's back in the news um about
the twitter deal guys the twitter deal
possibly being in jeopardy and that is
according to a report that came out
today in the washington post um
according to the washington post they
say this deal is in quote serious
jeopardy they they cite three three
people familiar with the matter um they
said that elon musk's team has stopped
engaging in certain discussions around
funding for that 44 billion uh dollar
deal
um
including with a party named as a likely
backer that's according to one of their
sources
um all of these sources spoke on the
condition of anonymity but they said
talks with investors have cooled in
recent weeks as musk
camp has raised doubts about the recent
data fire hose a trove of data sold to
corporate customers they received from
twitter musk teams doubts also
um doubts about the spam figures signal
that they believe they do not have
enough information to evaluate twitter's
prospects as a business that's according
to those sources
um
so it sounds like the spam accounts are
not the only reason
um you might want out of the deal here
i
this is uh annoying to some degree right
like i'm totally on board with checking
some of this stuff and i probably
believe that it's significantly higher
uh at least somewhat higher but probably
significantly higher than twitter leads
on um again he has more evidence than
anyone at this point they've given him
uh data files i believe they showed him
how they calculate this stuff and
they've tried to be somewhat transparent
at least it seems around how they're
going to or how they do determine these
numbers today so i think at some point
it's like
how are you supposed to feel about this
right like you signed a binding
agreement to buy a company
you waived all the due diligence that
one associated with that and now you're
coming back and asking for due diligence
around some of these things i get it
right it's a concern especially if
you're paying that amount of money and
using your time energy resources et
cetera to go build this company again
totally understand that that's uh
relevant but at the end of the day you
signed a binding agreement and now
you're forced with either continuing to
go through the deal paying a billion
dollar breakup fee or potentially
bringing them to court to maybe pay less
than that or maybe pay the billion
dollar fee anyways so it seems like he's
putting himself in an unfortunate
situation based on uh a metric uh that
even if it's they say what it's less
than five right maybe it's ten maybe
it's fifteen i don't know i have a hard
time believing it's fifty percent but at
the end of the day uh he has to get
comfortable with that number and he has
a few options right he can either
continue the deal he can go pay the
billion another break if he or he can
take him to court i think it's pretty
obvious at this point i think most
people just wanted to to proceed
yeah and also the market cap of twitter
right now is just at 28.4 billion so
much less than the uh 44 billion this is
hilarious the fact that he was chasing
twitter to buy them and now it's almost
reversed and twitter's like go ahead buy
us and he's like well now we gotta do
due diligence i was going off your sec
filings uh
look i'm sure they have a reason for
that five percent i'm sure the number's
lower than it actually is uh the number
that they reported uh but i'm sure they
have their methodology of how they
determine that and i know they've
probably shared it with elon uh but yeah
this is this is comical at this point
like look if you want to buy the company
do your due diligence do it you don't
have to be in the news every single day
about it um i know shareholders public
companies so a bunch of shareholders in
twitter very curious about what's going
on with it i know the employees at
twitter are curious about what's going
on with it uh everyone's just kind of
waiting on the sidelines so it's go
ahead do your due diligence and move
forward understandable elon's also
trying to get to mars he's got other
stuff going on so this isn't what he's
working on 24 7. if you can get to mars
you can delete spam accounts you guys
think the deal is going to happen
uh i'm increasingly thinking it's not
going to happen kind of with every day
that goes by where this continues
i think the unfortunate position is that
uh right he he agreed to pay basically
double what the company's worth today
depending on kind of how you look at her
close to it i guess right and uh it's
obviously dropped a lot in value maybe
he feels like he they got one over on
him he's paying an unfair price the
company's not worth this much or
whatever but ultimately that's what he
agreed to and uh if he does what he
thinks he'll be able to do with the
company how he's talked about it
building this kind of central hub
freedom of speech all these things it
should be worth much more than he's
paying for the company so
i think it just needs to move on at this
point like you're either willing to
proceed with kind of how you are
comfortable with the metrics or you're
going to take them to court or pay the
billion dollar faith yeah do you think
he was worried about that billion dollar
fee you think he like thinks about it or
is that like ten dollars to me and you
or five dollars you know billion dollars
billion dollars yeah so he's definitely
thinking about it and he wouldn't have
made the bid with that contingency
unless not not only that but it's
probably not as simple as like here's a
billion dollars were broken up imagine
there's a lot more that goes into it and
i mean and i imagine it's not just uh uh
that's probably option three out of
those right like
if he's not going to proceed i assume
it's some kind of uh legality trying to
get out of it right of saying hey look
this was not uh truthful this was a
misrepresentation of what i believe the
data to say all those things and maybe
that works i don't know i'll leave that
to other people to speculate on but i
don't think he's just gonna write a
billion dollar check and the other thing
to look at is that uh he's not alone in
this right he's brought in outside
investors now uh who have said that he's
stopped communicating with them or his
team has stopped communicating with them
or there's a lack of communication there
so it's not just himself now that's
involved in this and those investors
have backed other businesses of his he's
been involved in those investors for
years so i think to some play here like
you don't want to ruin relationships you
don't want to ruin your reputation
around these people which i don't
necessarily think that he's doing i'm
sure there's been communication to some
degree and they have some kind of inside
knowledge on what he's doing um but at
the end of the day i think that it needs
to proceed right people need to figure
out kind of what's going on this is this
has been in limbo
or in peril as they said for months now
yeah for months um
you shared an interesting story today
with the report that i feel like was
kind of underreported about the remember
the paycheck protection program ppp
wow um so the st louis fed put out a
study today or not today sorry they put
it out um this week
uh
saying uh there are a couple things that
stood out here but um
the bulk of those funds did not go to
the workers the rank and file workers
where the cash was intended
so
i don't know if you want to dig into
this one here but
it was supposed to be relief as you all
remember for small businesses during the
coven 19 crisis
and the study from the st louis fed
found that ppp was not well targeted
about one quarter of those funds
i guess supported those jobs
uh in addition this study also found
that ppp's benefits flow
disproportionately to wealthier
households and we'll get into that i'll
bring this up because according to this
study from the st louis fed about 20 to
25 of unemployment insurance payments
went to households with incomes in the
top 20
of the national distribution while just
10 to 15 of those stimulus checks up to
1200 per adult and 500 per qualifying
child went to households with that level
of income the greater progressivity of
the latter was due primarily to income
caps limiting eligibility eligibility
here
um
yeah so
you said 75
that's what this report says so that is
insane but yeah so 75 i think was the
headline number that uh basically went
elsewhere then to employees so for every
four dollars that went uh elsewhere one
dollar went to employees it's basically
uh relatively kind of the way to think
about it and then the other thing i
found interesting in the report was that
uh they obviously had numbers around
kind of how many jobs were saved which
was the original intention it was to
keep businesses afloat that couldn't go
do these things and to preserve their
employees right so you're supposed to be
using it for wages to keep people
employed while your doors were closed or
et cetera so it says that uh the ppp
loans boosted employment by between four
and ten percent in mid-may 2020 and by
zero to six percent by the end of the
year their best evidence is that almost
three million jobs per week were
preserved by the ppp program in the
second quarter of 2020 and nearly 2
million jobs per week were preserved in
the fourth quarter so that sounds like a
pretty good headline number right we're
saving millions of jobs with this money
but on aggregate when you look at the
total we obviously know a lot of that
money went to uh
was essentially stolen in some degree
right people were were uh uh
intentionally deceiving the government
and trying to receive those funds and
then a lot of the money just wasn't used
for
employees so for every one job saved uh
for one year that cost a hundred and
seventy thousand 000 to 258 000
which was much higher than the average
they were expecting of 58 200 based on
previous evidence so basically three to
four or five times more per employee
they paid than they were expecting to
pay based on money going elsewhere or
funds being stolen or et cetera right so
i think uh
the headline number you know you hear
800 billion dollars the ppp program and
everyone's like you know that seems like
a lot of money but in the context of the
government and kind of their spending
programs maybe it's really not all that
much money
but at the end of the day i think the
interesting part is sure it saved a
couple million jobs but the program was
by and large extremely ineffective when
it came to uh the distribution of these
funds not only distribution on the
employee side but the business decide we
see that
wealthier households or wealthier
businesses or companies were receiving
them in a disproportionate amount and
they weren't actually even being given
to employees in a lot of cases so while
a couple million employees were helped
and that's certainly significant they
obviously could have done an extremely a
much better job at distributing these
funds and and again it's not easy i
don't think anyone says it's easy but at
the end of the day it's pretty
disappointing that you know 75 of the
money went elsewhere we probably just
need to like do like a
post i don't know how effective it would
be like a post-mortem of all the
policies um from this
in the last two years just to evaluate
like maybe in the future um how these
things might play out if only 25
of employees actually got the money that
was sent it was only 25 effective in my
mind if you got money sent to you that
was meant for your employees and you
kept it or you used it for other things
you're just a bad dude that's i i'm
holding in a lot of words because that's
just that's just rude to do when people
are already going through such a hard
time uh as a business owner you might be
going through a hard time as well but
the government didn't just hand you
money that handed it to be passed down
to your employees i don't know all the
intricate to the program how the money
was supposed to be sent out i do know
the government had to try to send out a
lot of money over a trillion dollars
within a very short amount of time
including the stimulus and ppp loans
it's very very hard to do that
uh so i i give them a little credit
because it's just hard to do that from
scratch to just be like let's send it
out to everyone uh but then again a lot
of it was stolen a lot of bad actors uh
happened over the last two years the
unfortunate part is right that
essentially what's happening is is
there's money being printed that's
devaluing your money and then that money
that's being printed is not even going
to help you right so like the
expectation was that you were your money
was being devalued to help people in
need right and not only your money but
everyone's money was being devalued to
help people in need and give assistance
to people that uh would otherwise be
fired or not be able to work because of
the government regulation and
restrictions that were put in place due
to covid so to hear that not only was
that money uh devalued but the money
actually wasn't even given to the
employees extremely disappointing
obviously and it makes the whole
situation even that much worse someone
made a good point 75
so 600 billion dollars
wasted well
you guys are great um i hope you guys
have a great weekend thank you so much
for joining me today um of course of
course any parting thoughts
i hope everyone has a great weekend as
always you only get one friday make it
count whoa one friday a week that is